all right this morning we are talking
about inflation but not the kind you
think no it is the bling bling jam
balloon convention at binions downtown
where we find mary jane belliesa covered
in well where are your balloons mary
jane what's going on
i mean i'm gonna get another one here
obviously they're in the back making
them right now i'm joined by two balloon
artists i have eileen smith and i have
roxanne cardo right next to me i mean
look at their balloon hats though those
are pretty awesome i love that and you
know roxanne we were talking a little
bit about how much you were looking
forward to doing some of the classes
here and that includes a dress class
correct yes there'll be a dress making
class today where you can actually wear
the dress so i'm looking forward to
debbie stevens class today
i'll be anxiously awaiting i love that
and what about for you eileen what are
you looking most forward to just having
lots of fun and learning the cutting
edge and balloons so i can make party's
the happiest ever
how long does it take for you to kind of
put everything together
it all depends i take months rolling and
preparing my balloons choosing my
designs and i just have fun i lose track
of time
i'm a balloon geek
a balloon that's the first one i've
heard of that before and what about for
you roxanne i know you said that when
you're putting balloons together what
really brings you joy is just really
seeing how much people enjoy playing
with them yes the people they get
excited like i have a delivery van and i
open up the back two doors and they're
ecstatic they're like some adults are
jumping up and down
and they want to help pull out the
designs and you know you got to slow
their roll a little bit and
they just enjoy them immensely that's
perfect a lot of joy well thank you so
much to you both i mean i know that we
really enjoyed having you guys here
thank you so much and so i'm going to
come back around i know that we have
been talking all about trying to make
a balloon animal here and that means a
balloon dog it is one in the making so
what are we looking at here patrick we
are looking at your very first balloon
dog which is the three twist dog this is
the easiest balloon that we teach oh boy
so i'm gonna just literally
uh if we can have somebody hold her
microphone she's going to need to have
two hands here
thank you sir so here you go we're going
to start with this balloon right here
and what we're going to do is we're
going to start off like this are you
left handed to right hand right hand
you're right-handed you and i are going
to mirror each other so you're going to
do exactly as i do
because i'm left-handed okay so we're
going to start here we always start from
the knot okay and go down okay so all
we're going to do is start here like so
okay and we're going to bend it we're
going to grab that
we're going to squeeze off enough so
that we have a little bit for a nose
here and this is going to be atop the
head
and go ahead and twist that
as you pinch it and twist at the same
time you're going to pinch it twist both
sections oh boy yep so i'll help you out
in this person you have to help me out
with all of this oh i think he'll be
okay here we go so now you hold your
doggy upside down so his little nose
sticks up right and we're going to take
it like this this would be his neck this
is his legs go ahead and bend that over
and
pinch it nice and tight
like and make sure you have enough room
for your neck okay
and then go ahead and twist that
and that's your first set of legs okay
and if you look you're starting to see a
dog nose head legs go ahead and turn
them under one more time
remember that we're going to have a body
section here
so you want to place this hand up over
there you go and go ahead and bend it
all right and
we're going to give it one more squeeze
and twist
doesn't have to be noisy if you know
what you're doing it's not that perfect
but i think you know what i think it's
good right